ยินดีต้อนรับกลับสู่ Quantum Computing in Practice ฉัน Olivia Lanes และตอนที่สามนี้จะโฟกัสที่
การทดลอง QAOA ที่ระดับ utility scale ถ้าอยู่กับเรามาตั้งแต่ต้น คุณได้เห็นเราพาดู
IBM Quantum Hardware, framework ของ Qiskit patterns และเทคนิค error mitigation ล่าสุดที่
นักวิจัยและนักพัฒนาใช้ scale up Quantum circuit เรารู้สึกว่ามันสำคัญมากที่จะให้ context ทั้งหมดนี้
และแสดงทิศทางที่เราไป แต่ตอนนี้ไม่มีเหตุผลที่จะรอต่อไปแล้ว มาดูข้อมูลทั้งหมดนี้ในทาง
ปฏิบัติกันเลย สิ่งที่ต้องจำก่อนเริ่มคือทุกอย่างจะทำตาม framework ของ Qiskit
patterns เราจะทำตามขั้นตอนเหล่านี้ตามลำดับ หนึ่งคือ mapping the problem สองคือ optimizing the circuit สาม
คือ executing with Primitives และสี่คือ post-processing หรือการวิเคราะห์ผลลัพธ์ เราจะเริ่มด้วยตัวอย่างเล็ก ๆ ก่อน
เพื่อให้ทุกคนเข้าใจขั้นตอนและวัตถุประสงค์ได้ดีที่สุด แล้วเราจะพูดถึงตัวอย่างที่คล้ายกันแต่ใหญ่กว่ามาก
เพื่อแสดงวิธี scale up ปัญหาไปสู่ระดับ 100 qubit ฉันจะให้
เครื่องมือทั้งหมดเพื่อให้คุณไปข้างหน้าหลังจาก lecture นี้และรันปัญหานั้นด้วยตัวเอง สุดท้าย นี่จะไม่ใช่
การดู code ทีละบรรทัด ไม่ว่าจะพยายามแค่ไหน เมื่อเราก้าวหน้า code ก็เก่าและ deprecated ดังนั้นถ้า
ดู video นี้ปีหลังจากที่ออก ฉันไม่อยากให้คุณติดอยู่กับ syntax ที่อาจเปลี่ยนไปเล็กน้อยตามเวลา แต่นี่จะเป็น
การพูดถึง logic และ problem statement อย่างละเอียด อย่างไรก็ตามมี notebook tutorial ที่คู่กับ
video นี้แนบไว้ในคำอธิบายด้านล่าง การทำตาม code หรืออ้างอิงหลังดู
lesson นี้และรันด้วยตัวเองจะให้ประสบการณ์การเรียนที่ดีที่สุด ดังนั้นเตือนอย่างรวดเร็วว่าไม่ใช่
ทุกปัญหาการคำนวณเหมาะสำหรับ Quantum Computing ปัญหาง่ายและการคำนวณง่าย ๆ ไม่ต้องใช้
ประโยชน์จากเทคโนโลยีนี้เพราะคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิกแก้ได้ดีอยู่แล้ว ณ ปี 2024
สาม domain ที่เราหวังมากสุดที่จะสำรวจคือ การจำลองธรรมชาติ การประมวลผลข้อมูลที่มี
โครงสร้างซับซ้อน และสุดท้ายคือ optimization ปัญหา optimization เป็นปัญหาการคำนวณ
ที่ยากที่สุดที่จะแก้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ ในปัญหา optimization คุณกำลังมองหาค่าที่ใหญ่หรือเล็กที่สุดที่เป็นไปได้
สำหรับ cost function ที่กำหนด อย่างไรก็ตามสำหรับหลายปัญหาที่สนใจ การหา extremum นี้จะยิ่ง
ยากขึ้นแบบ exponential ตามขนาดของปัญหา นั่นเป็นเหตุผลที่มันยากมากในการคำนวณ ตัวอย่างเช่น ลองนึกดูว่า
ยากแค่ไหนในการคำนวณ flight path ที่ optimal หรือเส้นทางจัดส่งทั่วประเทศ ใน lesson นี้เราจะ
สำรวจปัญหา optimization เฉพาะที่เรียกว่า Max Cut ซึ่งเราจะแก้โดยใช้ Quantum
algorithm ที่เรียกว่า quantum approximate optimization algorithm หรือ QAOA ดังนั้น Max Cut problem คืออะไร?
Max Cut problem คือประเภทของ combinatorial optimization problem ที่นิยามบน graph โดยเป้าหมายคือ
แบ่ง vertex ของ graph ออกเป็นสอง subset เพื่อให้จำนวน edge ระหว่างสอง subset
มากที่สุด ตัวอย่างเช่น ใน graph นี้ แต่ละ node เชื่อมต่อแบบนี้ และ max cut แสดงโดยเส้นหยักนี้
ที่แบ่ง node ออกเป็นกลุ่มม่วงและกลุ่มเทา วิธีทำสิ่งนี้โดยผ่าน edge ให้มากที่สุดที่เป็นไปได้
คือตัด 5 edge สำหรับ graph นี้ เนื่องจาก graph เล็กมาก
ไม่ยากที่จะลอง cut ที่เป็นไปได้บนกระดาษหรือแม้แต่ในหัว และรู้ว่า 5 เป็นตัวเลือกที่ดีที่สุดที่เป็นไปได้
แต่ลองนึกดูถ้าจำนวน node เพิ่มเป็นสองเท่าแล้วสามเท่า อย่างรวดเร็วมันจะเป็นไปไม่ได้ที่จะทำ
ด้วยมือ และหลังจากจำนวนหนึ่ง มันยากมากจนแม้แต่ supercomputer ก็ไม่สามารถ return คำตอบที่ดีที่สุดได้อย่างน่าเชื่อถือ เพราะ
จำนวน cut สูงสุด scale แบบ exponential ตามจำนวน node แม้สิ่งนี้อาจดู abstract เล็กน้อย
มีปัญหา real world มากมายที่สามารถเปลี่ยนเป็น Max Cut problem เช่น fraud detection ในด้านการเงิน, graph
clustering, Network design, VLSI design รวมถึง social media analysis
ตัวอย่าง social media เข้าใจง่ายเป็นพิเศษ สมมติต้องการหากลุ่มบุคคลที่มีการเชื่อมต่อมากที่สุดที่เป็นไปได้
กับบุคคลอื่นบนแพลตฟอร์ม social media เพื่อ identify power user หรือคนที่มี
อิทธิพลมากที่สุดในกลุ่ม บริษัทจริง ๆ พยายามทำสิ่งนี้บ่อยมาก จุดสุดท้ายหนึ่งที่นี่ max cut มักเป็น
subroutine ของปัญหาใหญ่กว่า ดังนั้นมันอาจไม่ได้นิยาม application จริง แต่ใช้ภายใต้ hood มัน
พบบ่อยกว่าที่คุณอาจนึกถึงในตอนแรก ตอนนี้ถึงเวลาเริ่มต้นแล้ว
ขั้นตอนแรกคือสร้าง graph ทำได้โดย import Python package ที่เรียกว่า rustworkx กำหนดว่า
มี node กี่ตัวที่ทำงานด้วยโดยระบุจำนวน n แล้วเพิ่ม node ลง graph G คุณยังต้อง
draw edge ของคุณ เราจะทำด้วยมือที่นี่โดยแค่ list มันออกมาใน array แบบนี้ โดยแสดงตัวเลขสุดท้าย
ที่ระบุ weight ของ edge หรือว่า node สองตัวที่ระบุเชื่อมต่อกันแน่นแค่ไหน ที่นี่เรา
จะใช้ weight เป็น 1 ทั้งหมด แต่คุณอาจสนุกกับการทดลองปรับ weight ในภายหลังและดูว่า solution
เปลี่ยนแปลงอย่างไร เพื่อเข้าใจว่า weight หมายความว่าอะไรในบริบทนี้ กลับไปที่ตัวอย่าง social media คุณนึกถึง
weight นี้ว่าคนหนึ่งมีอิทธิพลต่ออีกคนมากแค่ไหน การเชื่อมต่อกับคู่สมรสหรือญาติของคุณ
เช่น อาจได้ weight สูงกว่าคนที่แค่รู้จักกัน ตอนนี้ draw graph ของคุณ
tutorial ที่แนบจะแสดง syntax ที่ถูกต้องก่อนที่จะพิจารณาวิธี
map ปัญหานี้ลง Quantum circuit มาสร้าง context ว่า max cut problem กลายเป็น optimization
problem ได้อย่างไรตั้งแต่แรก เราเริ่มด้วยการพิจารณา minimization ของฟังก์ชัน f(x) โดย input X คือ
vector มิติ n ซึ่ง component สอดคล้องกับแต่ละ node ของ graph เราจะเรียกฟังก์ชันนี้ต่อไปว่า
cost function ของเรา แล้วต้อง constrain component เหล่านี้แต่ละตัวให้เป็นศูนย์หรือ
หนึ่ง ที่นี่หมายถึงอยู่ฝั่งใดฝั่งหนึ่งของ cut เราสามารถเขียนฟังก์ชันเป็น
คู่ของ node x_i และ x_j ที่บอกเราว่า edge ที่สอดคล้องอยู่ใน cut ไหม ดังนั้นบวก ค่า x_i + x_j
ลบ x_i * x_j จะบอกว่า edge อยู่ใน cut ไหม ถ้าค่านี้เท่ากับ
หนึ่ง หมายความว่า edge อยู่ใน cut ไม่เช่นนั้นมันเป็นศูนย์และ edge ไม่ได้อยู่ ปัญหาในการหา
จำนวน edge สูงสุดใน cut จึงสามารถ formulate เป็นการ maximize ฟังก์ชันนี้ ถัดไปเราจะ
เพิ่ม global minus sign ให้ฟังก์ชันนี้ ทำให้ปัญหาใหม่เทียบเท่าการหา minimum ของฟังก์ชันนี้
แทน ดังนั้น minimum ของ f(x) ในกรณีนี้จะเป็นเมื่อจำนวน edge ที่ผ่าน cut มี
ค่า maximal เราเลือก frame ปัญหานี้เป็น minimization problem เพราะช่วยให้เรา map มันลง energy
minimization problem หรือการหา ground state ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเก่งโดยธรรมชาติ
แต่จำไว้ว่ายังไม่มีอะไรเกี่ยวกับ Quantum Computing ที่นี่ เรายังต้อง reformulate ปัญหานี้เป็น
สิ่งที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเข้าใจได้ ตอนนี้เราพร้อมที่จะเริ่มทำงานจริงแล้ว และ
ขั้นตอนแรกคือ map ปัญหาลง Quantum circuit อาจไม่ชัดเจนว่าเราจะ
ไปจาก graph แบบที่เพิ่ง draw มาสู่ Quantum circuit ได้อย่างไร แต่มาค่อย ๆ ดูกัน จำไว้ว่าเรา
กำลังพยายามแก้ Max Cut problem นี้โดยใช้ QAOA ใน QAOA algorithm เราต้องการ operator
ที่เป็น Hamiltonian ซึ่งจะใช้แทน cost function ของปัญหา รวมถึง parameterized
circuit หรือ ansatz หรือ trial state ที่เราจะใช้แทน Quantum state ที่เป็นการเดาอย่างมีหลักการหรือ candidate
สำหรับ solution ของปัญหา เราสามารถ sample จาก candidate state เหล่านี้แล้ว evaluate
โดยใช้ cost function ในกรณีนี้ cost function คือ f(x) แต่เราต้องแสดงมันใน
แบบที่รู้สึกเป็นธรรมชาติสำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม สำหรับสิ่งนี้เราจะใช้ประโยชน์จาก mathematical
transformation ชุดหนึ่งเพื่อแสดง f(x) เป็น energy function หรือ Hamiltonian ขั้นตอนแรกของ
กระบวนการคือแสดงปัญหาการ minimize f(x) เป็น quadratic unconstrained binary optimization
problem หรือ QUBO ย่อ ๆ QUBO เป็นวิธีทั่วไปในการ formulate combinatorial optimization problem เหล่านี้
ที่นี่ Q คือ matrix n×n ของจำนวนจริง n สอดคล้องกับจำนวน
node ใน graph ของเรา ห้าตัวสำหรับตัวอย่างนี้ และ X คือ vector เดียวกันของตัวแปร binary จาก
formulation เริ่มต้น เพื่อ run QAOA algorithm อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพเราต้อง express optimization problem ของเราในรูป
Hamiltonian ซึ่งเป็น mathematical operator ที่แทน energy รวมของระบบ โดยเฉพาะเราต้องการ
สร้าง cost function Hamiltonian ที่มีคุณสมบัติว่า ground state energy หรือค่า eigenvalue ต่ำสุด
สอดคล้องกับ minimum ของฟังก์ชันที่ encode จำนวน cut สูงสุดบน graph G เมื่อเรา
มี Hamiltonian นี้ สิ่งที่ต้องทำเพื่อแก้ optimization problem คือเตรียม ground state ของ Hamiltonian บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม แล้ว
การ sample จาก state นี้จะให้ solution ของการ minimize f(x) ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นสูง ปรากฏว่า
เราโชคดีเพราะ QUBO problem มีความสัมพันธ์ใกล้ชิดมากกับและจริง ๆ มีความเทียบเท่าทางคำนวณกับ
หนึ่งใน Hamiltonian ที่มีชื่อเสียงที่สุดใน physics คือ Ising Hamiltonian เพื่อเขียน QUBO
problem เป็น Ising Hamiltonian นี้ สิ่งที่ต้องทำจริง ๆ คือเปลี่ยนตัวแปรง่าย ๆ เพื่อไปจาก
Boolean variables 0 และ 1 เป็น spin variable ลบหนึ่งและบวกหนึ่ง ขั้นตอนนี้
ตรงไปตรงมา แสดงรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติมใน appendix ของ notebook ที่แนบสำหรับผู้ที่สนใจ แต่ท้ายที่สุด การ minimize QUBO
expression นี้เหมือนกับการ minimize expression นี้ เขียนใหม่อีกเล็กน้อยและ
เรามี cost function Hamiltonian ของเรา โดยที่ minimum ของ expression แทน ground state และ Z
กลายเป็น Pauli Z operator ในขณะที่ b คือ real scalar coefficient ตอนนี้ที่เรามี Hamiltonian
แล้ว มันตรงไปตรงมาที่จะเขียนมันในรูปของ ZZ Pauli operator local สองตัวที่จะ convert ได้ง่ายเป็น
สอง cubic gate ใน Quantum circuit โปรดดู notebook ที่แนบเพื่อดูวิธีทำสิ่งนี้ แต่ output
ได้จาก line นี้ สังเกตว่าในตัวอย่างของเรามี
หก object หรือ Pauli string เพราะแต่ละตัวแทน edge ใน graph ความยาวของ string ตรงกับจำนวน
node ดังนั้น IIIZZ คือ 5 node และ string จะประกอบด้วย
identity ในทุก position ยกเว้น index ของ node ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ edge ซึ่งจะมี Z term ใน Qiskit
bit string ที่แทน qubit จะ index ย้อนหลัง ตัวอย่างเช่น edge ระหว่าง node 0 และ 1 จะ encode เป็น
IIIZZ เมื่อเขียน Hamiltonian ในรูปของ Pauli เราพร้อม construct
Quantum circuit ของเรา Quantum circuit นี้จะช่วย sample solution ที่ดีจากคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม QAOA algorithm
ได้แรงบันดาลใจจาก adiabatic theorem ที่ระบุว่า ถ้าเราเริ่มใน ground state ของ time-dependent
Hamiltonian และถ้า Hamiltonian evolve ช้าพอและมีเวลาเพียงพอ final state จะเป็น ground
state ของ final Hamiltonian QAOA สามารถคิดเป็น discrete Trotter version ของ quantum
adiabatic algorithm โดยแต่ละ Trotter step แทน layer ที่เรียกว่า p ดังนั้น
แทนที่จะ evolve จาก state หนึ่งไปอีกตัว ในแต่ละ layer ของ p เราจะสลับไปมาระหว่าง cost
function Hamiltonian และสิ่งที่เรียกว่า mixer Hamiltonian ซึ่งเราจะได้ยินเพิ่มเติมในอีกสักครู่ แต่ประเด็นที่อยากทำให้ชัดคือ
QAOA มีข้อดีที่เร็วกว่า quantum adiabatic algorithm แต่ return approximate
solution แทน optimal ในขีดจำกัดที่จำนวน layer ไปสู่ infinity QAOA จะ converge ไปสู่ adiabatic
case แต่แน่นอนว่านี่แพงมากในด้านการคำนวณ เพื่อสร้าง Quantum circuit ของเรา
เราจะ apply alternating operator ที่นี่ parameterize ด้วย gamma และ beta ซึ่ง
จะแทน discretization ของ time Evolution ดังนั้นสามส่วนหลักของ
QAOA circuit คือหนึ่ง initial trial state สีเทา ซึ่งเป็น ground
state ของ mixer จาก adiabatic state of evolution สร้างโดย apply Hadamard gate กับทุก qubit สอง
cost function Evolution ที่เรามีแล้วสีม่วงเข้ม และสาม evolution ภายใต้ mixer
Hamiltonian ที่ยังไม่ได้พูดถึงสีม่วงอ่อน ตอนนี้ starting Hamiltonian ของเราเรียกว่า
mixer เพราะ ground state ของมันคือ superposition ของ bit string ที่เป็นไปได้ทั้งหมดที่สนใจ ดังนั้น
enforce mixture ของทุก solution ที่เป็นไปได้ตั้งแต่ต้น mixer Hamiltonian คือ sum ง่าย ๆ ของ Pauli X
operation บนแต่ละ node ของ graph Qiskit ให้คุณใช้ mixer operator custom ต่างกันถ้าต้องการ แต่
สำหรับกรณีนี้เราจะใช้ standard ดังนั้นอีกครั้ง คุณเห็นว่าด้วย Qiskit งานส่วนใหญ่ถูก
ลบออกสำหรับเรา ทำให้การคิด mixer Hamiltonian และ starting State เป็นเรื่องง่าย งานเดียวที่ต้องทำคือ
หา cost function แต่ละ iteration ของ operator เหล่านี้เรียกว่า layer layer เหล่านี้มองได้เป็น
discretization ของ time evolution ของระบบตามที่อธิบายก่อน pattern สลับกันมาจาก
Trotter decomposition และ approximate exponential function ของ non-commuting matrix โดยทั่วไปยิ่ง layer หรือ
step ที่รวมมีมากขึ้น เราจะใกล้ continuous time Evolution มากขึ้น ดังนั้นในทางทฤษฎีผลลัพธ์จะแม่นยำมากขึ้น
แต่สำหรับตัวอย่างนี้เราจะเริ่มด้วยการ sample ด้วย 2 layer จำไว้ว่าทั้ง cost function Hamiltonian และ
mixer มี parameter เรายังต้องหาค่า optimal สำหรับ gamma และ
beta ตอนนี้ฉันรู้ว่านั่นเป็นข้อมูลมาก และถ้าเห็น math ประเภทนี้ครั้งแรกมันอาจยาก โชคดีหนึ่งใน
สิ่งที่เยี่ยมเกี่ยวกับ Qiskit คือสิ่งที่เราพึ่งผ่านส่วนใหญ่ทำได้อัตโนมัติโดยไม่ต้องให้ user ทำมาก มันดีที่เข้าใจว่าเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นภายใต้ hood โดยเฉพาะเมื่อ scale up สู่การทดลองที่ใหญ่กว่า แต่คุณไม่ต้องทำงานทั้งหมดนี้
ด้วยมือทุกครั้ง ตอนนี้เรา map ปัญหาลง Quantum circuit แล้ว มันเป็นงานนิดหน่อย
แต่ไม่ต้องกังวล มันจะง่ายขึ้นและ intuitive มากขึ้นยิ่งทำมากขึ้น ตอนนี้พร้อมย้ายไปขั้นตอนที่สอง
การ optimize circuit สำหรับ hardware ดังนั้นแม้ circuit ที่เพิ่งสร้างดูเรียบง่ายและ
มีประโยชน์ในการสร้าง intuitive understanding จำไว้ว่า quantum chip ไม่เข้าใจ abstract
block นี้ เราต้องแปลงมันเป็นชุด 1 และ 2 qubit gate ที่เป็น native ต่อ hardware และเมื่อ
พูดว่า native หมายถึงมันจะถูก refactor เป็นสิ่งที่สามารถทำได้โดยตรงบน qubit circuit ดังกล่าวเรียกว่า
เขียนใน instruction set architecture ของ backend ซึ่งอาจเห็นย่อว่า ISA circuit
Qiskit SDK transpiler module มี series ของ transpilation pass ที่สามารถ
ทำ circuit transformation หลากหลาย เราต้องการให้แน่ใจว่า circuit ของเรา optimize สำหรับ
วัตถุประสงค์ของเรา จำจาก lesson ก่อนว่า transpilation process เกี่ยวข้องกับหลายขั้นตอน: การ map
qubit ใน circuit หรือ decision variable ไปยัง physical qubit บน device, การ unroll instruction ใน
quantum circuit เป็น hardware native instruction ที่ backend จริง ๆ เข้าใจ, การ route qubit
ใน circuit ที่ interact กันโดยตรงไปยัง physical qubit ที่อยู่ติดกัน
และเสมอมีรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติมหาได้บน documentation
site ตอนนี้มาถึงขั้นตอนที่น่าตื่นเต้นที่เราจะเลือก backend ที่จะ run circuit บนมัน เราต้องทำสิ่งนี้จริง ๆ
ก่อนขั้นตอน transpilation เพราะ transpiler optimize ต่างกันสำหรับ processor ต่างกัน นี่เป็นอีกเหตุผลที่
สำคัญที่ Qiskit สามารถ automate ขั้นตอนนี้ไปมากขนาดนั้น คุณไม่อยากต้อง optimize circuit ด้วยมือ
ซึ่งทำได้แต่บางครั้งยากและใช้เวลามาก แล้วพบว่าจริง ๆ อยากรัน
circuit บน processor ต่างกันที่มี property ต่างกัน แล้วต้องทำงานนั้นทั้งหมดอีกครั้ง ส่ง
backend ที่เลือกผ่าน transpiler function และอย่าลืมระบุ optimization level ครั้งนี้
ฉันเลือก optimization level 3 ซึ่งสูงสุดและ exhaustive ที่สุด
และนั่นคือทั้งหมดสำหรับขั้นตอนที่สอง circuit ของฉันถูก transpile อัตโนมัติและฉัน draw ไว้ที่นี่เพื่อให้
คุณเห็นว่ามันถูก translate เป็น 1 และ 2 qubit gate อย่างไร ตอนนี้ถึงเวลาขั้นตอนที่สาม
การ run circuit ด้วย Qiskit Primitives จนถึงตอนนี้เรา transpile circuit โดยปล่อยให้ parameter gamma และ
beta ไว้ แต่เราไม่สามารถ run circuit ได้จริงโดยไม่ระบุค่าของ parameter เหล่านี้ ใน QAOA
workflow parameter QAOA ที่ optimal หาได้ใน iterative optimization loop ที่เรา run circuit
evaluation ชุดหนึ่งและใช้ classical optimizer หา parameter beta และ gamma ที่ optimal อย่างไรก็ตามเราต้องเริ่มที่
ไหนสักที่ ดังนั้นฉัน implement initial guess สำหรับ gamma_1, gamma_2 และ beta_1, beta_2 เป็น π/2 และ π
ตามลำดับ ฉันยังอยากให้คุณสังเกตว่าเราจะใช้ optimizer หา solution ที่ดีกว่าสำหรับ gamma และ beta
และเนื่องจากฉัน calculate แค่ 2 layer ตอนนี้นั่นก็พอแล้ว แต่ถ้าทำ QAOA circuit ที่แม่นยำกว่า
คุณจะรวม layer มากขึ้นและต้องการ gamma และ beta ที่ optimize สำหรับแต่ละ sequential
layer ตอนนี้ขอหยุดสักครู่และจำตัวเลือกสำหรับ Primitives เรามี estimator และ
sampler คุณคิดว่าเราจะใช้ตัวไหนสำหรับงานประเภทนี้? ไม่ว่าคุณจะเดาตัวไหน
คุณถูกจริง ๆ เราจะใช้ทั้ง estimator และ sampler สำหรับ initial optimization
loop เราต้องการ estimator แต่เราจะใช้ sampler ในภายหลังสำหรับการอ่าน final
solution ตอนนี้เราพร้อม run algorithm แล้ว ฉันสัญญา แต่รวดเร็วมากก็สำคัญที่จะสังเกตว่าคุณสามารถ
ส่ง job ได้หลายวิธีต่างกันซึ่งเรียกว่า execution mode ก่อนอื่นคือ job mode: single
primitive request ของ estimator หรือ sampler ที่ทำโดยไม่มี context manager circuit และ input ถูก package เป็น primitive
unified block หรือ PUB และส่งเป็น execution task บน quantum
computer batch mode คือ multi-job manager สำหรับ run การทดลองที่ประกอบด้วย bunch
ของ independent job อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ ใช้ batch mode ส่ง primitive job หลายตัวพร้อมกัน session mode คือ dedicated
window สำหรับ run multi-job workload ช่วยให้ premium user ทดลองกับ variational algorithm ในทาง
ที่ predictable มากขึ้น และยัง run การทดลองหลายอย่างพร้อมกันโดยใช้ประโยชน์จาก parallelism ของ
stack ใช้ session สำหรับ iterative workflow และการทดลองที่ต้องการ dedicated access สำหรับ QAOA experiment
session จะเป็นตัวเลือกที่ดีที่จะดำเนินการต่อถ้ามีสิทธิ์เข้าถึง เนื่องจากต้องลอง circuit หลายตัวสำหรับค่าต่าง ๆ ของ beta
และ gamma โอเค ตอนนี้กลับไปที่ optimization problem ของเรา เรา define
cost function Hamiltonian HC แล้ว และ workflow ทั้งหมดเป็นดังนี้: QAOA
algorithm เริ่มด้วยการ initialize qubit ใน superposition state แล้ว apply ansatz ด้วย P layer มัน
initialize parameter gamma และ beta แล้ว run circuit โดยใช้ estimator primitive เมื่อเรา calculate
expectation value แล้ว เราจะใช้ SciPy optimizer ที่เรียกว่า COBYLA COBYLA
optimize cost function แบบ classical ภายนอก QPU เมื่อค่าของ gamma และ beta ถูก update แล้ว เรา
repeat เราจะทำสิ่งนี้จนค่าของ cost function รวมได้ converge และถึงค่าต่ำสุด
แล้วเราจะเลือกค่าของ gamma และ beta ที่สอดคล้องกับค่า cost ต่ำนี้และ run circuit ครั้งสุดท้าย
ครั้งนี้ใช้ sampler นี่คือผลลัพธ์จากการรัน COBYLA optimizer ด้วย initial guess ของฉัน ที่นี่คุณเห็น
ว่าค่าของ cost function ตลอด iteration ที่ทำเริ่มต้นยุ่งเล็กน้อยและขึ้นลง แต่
แล้วมันจะ settle ที่ค่าต่ำ เราจะใช้ค่า gamma และ beta สุดท้ายเหล่านี้ที่สอดคล้องกับ minimum cost
function evaluation เพื่อ run circuit ครั้งสุดท้ายและ sample bit string ที่จะให้ max
cut ตอนนี้โดยใช้ค่าที่ optimize แล้วสำหรับ gamma และ beta เราจะ run circuit ครั้งสุดท้ายเพื่อหา bit
string ที่ดีที่สุดโดยใช้ sampler ฉัน list ค่าเฉพาะที่ใช้ที่นี่ แต่จำไว้ว่าเมื่อคุณลอง
ด้วยตัวเองหรือแม้แต่ rerun tutorial notebook เดิม ค่าเหล่านี้อาจเปลี่ยนไปเล็กน้อย ตอนนี้เราจะ run
circuit ที่ optimize แล้วด้วยค่าเหล่านี้และหา candidate solution สำหรับ Max Cut problem ของเรา ถ้าใช้
session นั้นไม่จำเป็นแล้วเนื่องจากเราแค่ run job สุดท้ายหนึ่งครั้ง ตอนนี้เราจะดู
ขั้นตอน postprocessing และหา final solution ของเรา ก่อนอื่น plot ทุก
combination ที่เป็นไปได้ของ node ที่เรา convert เป็น bit string เป็น histogram คุณเห็นทันทีว่า
เมื่อฉันรัน ฉันพบ 4 solution และ highlight สีม่วงที่มีความน่าจะเป็นมากกว่า solution อื่น
bit string solution ที่สูงสุดและน่าจะเป็นมากที่สุดคือ 01010 โปรดสังเกตว่าลำดับของ qubit
กลับกันใน plot มองที่ solution ที่น่าจะเป็นมากที่สุด เราสังเกตว่า node 0 และ 3 ถูกจัดกลุ่มด้วยกัน
และเช่นเดียวกันสำหรับ node 1, 2 และ 4 ตอนนี้เรา plot bit string ที่น่าจะเป็นมากที่สุด
กลับเป็น graph ได้ และจำไว้ว่า bit string สอดคล้องกับหมายเลข node และถ้าพวกมัน include
ทำเครื่องหมายด้วย 1 หรือไม่ include ทำเครื่องหมายด้วย 0 ในการจัดกลุ่มของเรา เมื่อเรา draw cut ตอนนี้เราเห็นด้วยตาเปล่า
เส้น approximate สำหรับ cut ที่ดีที่สุดซึ่งแสดงการจัดกลุ่ม ideal ของ node ทั้ง 5 ตัวที่ฉัน draw ไว้ที่นี่ หนึ่ง
สิ่งที่อยากใช้เวลาพูดถึงที่นี่คือความจริงที่ว่า solution ที่ถูกต้องไม่ unique
เนื่องจาก symmetry ของ graph นี้มี solution ที่ถูกต้องหลายอย่าง แทนที่จะให้ node 0 และ 3 อยู่
ใน cut เราอาจให้ node 2 และ 4 include และคุณเห็นว่าสิ่งที่ฉันทำแค่ rotate cut เพื่อ
include จุดใหม่เหล่านี้ solution ของ 5 ยังคงเดิม
มาดู histogram และ 4 solution ที่น่าจะเป็นมากที่สุดอีกครั้ง solution สองตัวสุดท้ายคือ
ตัวที่เพิ่ง plot และถูกต้องเท่ากัน แต่ยังมีอีก เราสามารถ reverse coloring สำหรับ
solution ที่ถูกต้องทั้งหมดและครั้งนี้เราแค่คิดว่า node อยู่ inside เทียบกับ outside ของ cut บน
slide ก่อน เรา identify solution ที่ถูกต้อง unique 2 อย่าง แต่จริง ๆ มีอีก 2 solution หนึ่งสอดคล้องกับ
opposite ของแต่ละ ดูว่าที่นี่ที่ฉัน draw solution ที่เหลือสองอย่าง ฉันแค่ reverse
color ตอนนี้ปัญหาเดียวคือ algorithm จริง ๆ ไม่พบหรือ identify solution ที่สี่สุดท้ายนี้ว่า
เป็นหนึ่งใน 4 คำตอบที่น่าจะเป็นสูงสุด มันเป็นอันดับที่ 5 solution ที่สี่ที่ algorithm identify
จริง ๆ ไม่ถูกต้อง และถ้า draw มันคุณจะเห็นว่า solution นั้นมีแค่ 4 cut และเนื่องจากอื่น ๆ
มี 5 และ 4 น้อยกว่า 5 อย่างชัดเจน นี่ผิดอย่างชัดเจน ประเด็นที่นี่
คือนี่เป็น approximate algorithm มันไม่ผิดพลาดไม่ได้และไม่ถูกต้อง 100% ของเวลา คุณต้อง
ใช้ความรู้และความเข้าใจของตัวเองเพื่อ sanity check solution คุ้มค่าที่จะ highlight ว่า
error นี้อาจเกิดจากหลายที่ อาจเป็นลักษณะ approximate ของ algorithm เองและจำนวน layer เล็กน้อย
ที่ฉันเลือกใช้ อาจเป็น finite sampling error และสิ่งนี้จะลดลงถ้าเพิ่ม
จำนวน shot ในการทดลอง หรืออาจเป็น readout error เนื่องจาก solution จริงที่สี่อยู่ห่างแค่หนึ่ง
bit เหตุผลที่ชี้ให้เห็นความเป็นไปได้เหล่านี้ทั้งหมดเพราะนี่คือสิ่งที่ต้องใช้เพื่อกลายเป็น
practitioner ของ Quantum Computing คุณต้องเข้าใจ performance ของ hardware และวิธีที่มันสามารถ contribute
กับ error บางประเภทและวิธีแก้ไข อย่างไรก็ตาม อย่าลืมว่ามี
bit string solution ที่เป็นไปได้ 32 อย่าง และ 4 solution จริงอยู่ใน 5 อันดับแรก
ที่ดีที่สุด และฉันใช้แค่ 2 layer เพื่อหาสิ่งนี้ โดยทั่วไปถ้าต้องการเพิ่มโอกาสหา
Max Cut ที่ดีที่สุดทุกครั้ง ฉันจะเพิ่ม layer depth มีบางความละเอียดอ่อนสำหรับสิ่งนี้ แต่นั่นสำหรับ episode ถัดไป
ตอนนี้ฉันจะให้คุณลองด้วยตัวเอง แต่ครั้งนี้คุณจะใช้ 100
qubit ดังนั้นถ้าเริ่มด้วยการ draw 100 qubit graph คุณจะเห็นว่ามันไม่ straightforward หรือแม้แต่เป็นไปได้
ที่จะมองด้วยตาว่า max cut อยู่ที่ไหน มีความเป็นไปได้มากเกินไปที่จะเลือกด้วยมือ แต่
การแก้ปัญหานี้โดยใช้ QAOA ยังทำได้อย่างสมบูรณ์ และคุณสามารถทำตาม workflow เดียวกับที่ใช้สำหรับ 5
qubit ฉันกำลังจะส่งคุณออกไปเองและมอบหมายให้คุณลองทดลองนี้ แต่ก่อนนั้นมา
สรุป จำไว้ว่า 6 ขั้นตอนของ QAOA job ใด ๆ มีดังนี้ หนึ่งการนิยาม
cost Hamiltonian เพื่อให้ ground state encode solution ของ optimization problem สองการนิยาม
mixer Hamiltonian สามการสร้าง operator ที่สอดคล้องกับ exponentiated
Hamiltonian สี่การสร้าง circuit ซึ่งจะประกอบด้วย ground state เริ่มต้นของ mixer และสลับกัน
repeated layer ของ cost function และ evolution ภายใต้ mixer Hamiltonian ห้าเตรียม initial state และ
ใช้ classical computing technique เพื่อ optimize parameter หกรัน circuit วัด output bit string
มองหา solution ที่น่าจะเป็นมากที่สุด ตอนนี้บางสิ่งที่ต้องสังเกต ฉัน
ใช้ optimization level 3 สำหรับตัวอย่าง 5 qubit แต่นั่นอาจไม่จำเป็น และคำตอบที่ถูกต้องอาจ
ยัง return ได้ส่วนใหญ่ที่ optimization level ต่ำกว่า เพราะ circuit depth ค่อนข้างต่ำสำหรับ 5
qubit แต่สำหรับ 100 qubit และ circuit depth ใหญ่ คุณแทบแน่นอนต้องการ optimization level สูงสุด
เพื่อหาคำตอบที่ถูกต้อง รวมถึงจำไว้ว่าหนึ่งในส่วนที่ท้าทายที่สุดของ utility
scale workflow ทั่วไปคือขั้นตอน mapping และการหา graph ที่ correspond ดีกับ IBM heavy hex topology ถ้าคุณ
ทำงานนี้จาก scratch นั่นแน่นอนคือที่ที่คุณจะใช้เวลาส่วนใหญ่ สำหรับตอนนี้ส่วนนี้ถูก
ทำแล้วสำหรับคุณเพราะนั่นไม่ใช่ประเด็นหลักของการฝึกนี้ แต่จำไว้ว่ามันเป็นสิ่งที่เรา
ต้องการฝึกปฏิบัติ และการ run งานขนาดใหญ่ไม่ได้ straightforward เสมอ เราจะ delve เข้าสู่สิ่งนี้
ต่อไปใน episode 4 final circuit ของคุณจะดูยุ่งเหยิงกว่า circuit ที่ run บน 5 qubit อย่างชัดเจน
แต่ในทางกลับกัน ฉันรู้สึกว่าการดู circuit นี้และเห็นว่ามี gate กี่ตัวและรู้ว่าคุณ
มีความสามารถในการ run สิ่งนี้บน Quantum processor จริงนั้น
น่าประทับใจมาก และนี่คือ final solution ของฉัน คุณเห็นว่า algorithm สามารถจัดกลุ่ม
node เหล่านี้ออกเป็นสองกลุ่มได้อย่างชัดเจน ระบุ Max Cut ที่ดีที่สุดที่แบ่งพวกมันออกจากสองเซตไปสู่
max cut line นั้นง่ายมาก ที่ไหนก็ตามที่สีเปลี่ยนตาม line ที่เชื่อม node บ่งบอก
ว่าควร draw max cut line ที่ไหน เมื่อฉัน run มัน max cut value ที่ฉันทำได้คือ
84 ดังนั้นลองด้วยตัวเองและบอกฉันในคอมเมนต์ว่าได้ผลลัพธ์คล้ายกันไหม ลอง 3 layer บางที 4 ลอง
เปลี่ยน weight ระหว่าง node และดูว่าเปลี่ยน outcome อย่างไร มีการทดลองที่น่าสนใจมาก
ที่เราสามารถ run ด้วย QAOA จำไว้ว่ามันไม่ได้รับประกันว่าฉันเพิ่งพบ solution ที่ดีที่สุดที่เป็นไปได้
เรารู้ว่ามันเป็น solution ที่ดี แต่เพื่อความสนุก ฉัน challenge คุณให้ลองเอาชนะฉัน ดูว่าคุณจะได้สิ่งที่
ดีกว่า 84 ไหม สรุปแล้ว QAOA เป็น algorithm ที่ dynamic มาก
และมี heuristic มากมายและยังมีอีกมากที่ต้องสำรวจ มันให้พื้นที่มากในการเรียนรู้สิ่ง
ใหม่เกี่ยวกับสาขา optimization โดยทั่วไป มีงานมากมายเมื่อเร็ว ๆ นี้ใน optimization space ตาม
ที่แสดงโดย archive paper ทั้งหมดที่เพิ่งถูก publish ออนไลน์เกี่ยวกับ QAOA หรือ optimization และสิ่ง
ที่ cool จริง ๆ คือสุดท้ายไม่ใช่ paper ทั้งหมดเหล่านี้เป็น theory paper นักทฤษฎีทำงานและศึกษา
QAOA มาหลายปีแล้ว แต่ตอนนี้ experimentalist กำลังเข้ามามีส่วนร่วมเพราะตอนนี้เรามี hardware
เช่น processor ของ IBM ที่สามารถ run การทดลองเหล่านี้ได้มากมาย เรากำลังเคลื่อนจาก imaginative space
ไปสู่โลกจริงและนั่นน่าตื่นเต้นมาก ใช่ ยังมีงานที่ต้องทำอีกมากและยังมี
error มากมายที่ต้องหาวิธีจัดการ แต่เรากำลังก้าวหน้าอย่างรวดเร็ว และคุณที่ดู
video นี้ถ้ามาถึงตรงนี้ สามารถ run การทดลองเหล่านี้ด้วยตัวเองได้ ไปลอง run
100 qubit experiment ของตัวเองและบอกเราว่าเป็นอย่างไร ทำตาม tutorial แล้วคุณจะดีมาก และถ้า
มีคำถามหรือติดขัด ไม่ต้องกังวล เราทุกคนรู้สึกแบบนั้นหรือมีคำถามเหมือนกันตอนเริ่ม
เรียน ทำดีที่สุด บอกเราว่าเจอคำถามอะไรและเจอกันครั้งหน้า
[Music]